Speaker 1: Well, folks, we are not going to
be getting those Secret Service text messages.
Many of you I know have been following this
story this week, anxiously awaiting yesterday,
Tuesday, when supposedly the text messages
deleted by the Secret Service after they were
told, don't delete these text messages, preserve
records.
They are not going to be able to able to turn
them over to the January 6th committee investigating
the Trump riots.
This is a really, really big deal.
This really actually should be a major scandal.
And I don't know if it's going to become one
as it seems.
Even the Secret Service under Trump, which
we suspected, we talked about it at the time,
even the Secret Service under Trump, supposedly,
in theory, apolitical, has fallen fell under
the thumb of wacky Trumpism.
So let's reset the story.
The January six committee subpoenaed some
U.S. Secret Service records because a government
watchdog found believed that the agency had
erased two important text messages from January
5th and January 6th, 2021.
The Secret Service was told even if these
were deleted, you have to recover them.
And there were conflicting and changing explanations
as to why the Secret Service didn't have them
first.
It was something related to changes to the
pieces of equipment, elements of technology
that they were using.
They did a phone migration.
Well, it turns out that that phone migration
started after the request for these text messages.
So it's all increasingly more and more fishy.
And now we learn you're not going to get the
text messages.
Washington Post report.
Secret Service cannot okay, cannot recover
texts.
No new details for the January six committee.
The US Secret Service has determined it has
no new text messages to provide Congress relevant
to its January 6th investigation and that
any other texts its agents exchanged around
the time of the Trump riots were purged.
Purged.
Also, the National Archives sought more information
on the potential unauthorized deletion of
agency text messages.
The US government's chief record keeper asked
Secret Service to report back within 30 days
about the deletion of records, including describing
what was purged and the circumstances of how
the documentation was lost.
It's just gone, guys.
And yes, it's as suspicious as a situation
as it sounds.
It is amazing what you are unable to do when
you're determined not to do something.
And I'm reminded of Donald Trump and his tax
records.
Donald Trump was obviously, from day one,
determined never to publish his private tax
records.
It was abundantly clear.
And so first it was, well, I'm under audit,
as he like to say, from the IRS.
And once the audits are complete.
But wait, sir, which years are under audit?
Give us something.
It can't be that every year of recent taxes.
Well, I'm under audit.
I'm under audit.
And my lawyers say, don't do it.
Okay.
So then after it.
Well, no.
And well, now it's reelection.
It's four years later.
You're not still being audited for those same
years, are you?
Well, I don't know.
The American people don't care about that.
He was determined not to publish his tax returns.
And he didn't publish them.
The Secret Service here was clearly determined
not to recover or provide or publicize or
deliver these text messages.
And that's exactly what they're doing.
So now we have at least a reasonable suspicion
that Secret Service was involved, complicit,
indifferent to what was going on on January
6th.
Now, let's add to that add to our understanding
this seemingly strange data point.
Mike Pence didn't want to get in the car with
Secret Service on that day.
That's weird.
But we didn't really know what to make of
it, at least not initially.
It kind of doesn't make sense.
Why wouldn't the if Secret Service comes to
the vice president and says, Mr. Vice President,
sir, we've got to get you out of here, it's
not safe.
And Pence goes, I'm not going.
I'm not getting in a car with you guys.
That is strange.
But it was sort of out of context initially.
Do we now have a little bit more of the picture
where Secret Service here seemingly for what
appear to be political reasons?
I mean, there's been no other explanation
given the explanations about technological
reasons shifted.
So it was a data migration, it was new devices.
It was these different things that none of
it makes sense.
But what now does make some sense is the idea
that Pence knew what we are increasingly aware
of, which is that even the Secret Service
was not infiltrated but taken over by Trump
loyalists.
If you think back to when Trump was in the
hospital with COVID and on day two, Trump
insisted on going out for this joyride with
his mask on to wave to people around Walter
Reed Hospital.
And we all said that's hugely irresponsible.
He's stuffing a bunch of he's he's very sick
and he's stuffing Secret Service agents into
the vehicle.
And we heard anecdotally, oh, some of the
Secret Service agents didn't like it.
They were exposed a high rate of COVID among
them.
Maybe most of them are actually okay with
it.
I mean, at the end of the day, if it was Trump
loyalists handpicked, even within Secret Service
to be around, maybe they thought it was cool
that he was going around and saying hi to
the people.
So that's increasingly the picture we have
of Secret Service under Trump.
Now, separately, what's going on with Merrick
Garland?
Merrick Garland as attorney general.
And so far he's shown no willingness, willingness
to really go after high level people potentially
involved with criminality related to January
six, related to the post-election period.
What's going on at DOJ?
We don't know.
This is investigation worthy.
The Secret Service should be investigated
over these deleted texts by the highest level,
and that would be as a federal agency.
That would be by the Department of Justice.
Is that going to happen?
Is there any evidence Merrick Garland is willing
to do that?
It's an extraordinarily suspicious timeline.
Congress tells the Secret Service preserve
the documents from January five and six.
On January 16th.
It had only been ten days.
January 16th, 2021.
Congress says keep the documents.
And then again, they say that on January 25th
and then two days later.
This is now two weeks after being told keep
the records.
The Secret Service starts a phone migration
and all of a sudden it's all gone and we can't
get any of it.
This is major news.
This should be a major scandal.
We will see where
it goes.